hi I'm Linda Poland Abraham here at
Davos into the question of what one
thing and where companies do make the
world a better place in my view it
really comes down to find you but one
thing that you're passionate about
resources and money of course are
critical part of equation and you can
certainly be a lot of the world from all
three of those tip up and don't provide
download it really likes work at the end
of the day in mind a viewing April is
that the passion and the talent that
individual estate in order to make
writing organizing my arm is something
something artistic everybody has an
expression but they're really good at
really passionate about and I think
taking initiative to find an avenue for
that someone in the world a Connecticut
moment I think collectively if you begin
to think about it's really substantial
and that's 10 toes because there's so
many people doing that and it's really
very very inspiring so I hope to take
some advil and this is this
I don't like you I'm always you